he has ongoing studies of risk
assessment particularly with respect to
the criminal justice system we'll be
talking about making fair decisions
without this there's some work that I've
been doing with colleagues at Stanford
Emma Pearson and char go Cory get
Berkeley ivy fella and colleague at
University of Chicago disease hat so you
can I think this question of how can we
make their decisions without rhythms and
how this kind of started is we're
looking at how to identify bias in
algorithmic decisions and our background
is actually looking at bias in human
decisions so I started out looking at
whether police officers are
discriminating and who they decide to
search at a traffic stop and we thought
well algorithm decisions and human
decisions seem to be there are a lot of
similarities right in the end some what
you've got to decide who you're going to
search and whether it's an algorithm
making that decision or if you making
that decision maybe there's not that big
a difference so maybe we can apply some
of the things we've learned testing for
bias and human decisions to bias in
algorithmic decisions the case study
I'll talk about during this talk looks
at pretrial decision making right so if
you get arrested
you go before a judge and the judge has
to decide should you be detained before
your trial or should you be released and
the mandate is to ensure public safety
and that you'll appear in court while
releasing as many defendants as possible
and we want to do judges exhibit racial
bias in these decisions so there's a few
ways we might go about this and in this
talk I'll be using data from Broward
County that was made available by this
ProPublica study that you have heard
about already the first test is known as
the benchmark test and we just compare
the rates of detention between
comparable groups
so a typical statement here might be
like controlling for age and the number
of prior convictions like defendants are
three percentage points more likely to
be detained than white defendants and we
might argue that this is indicative of
discrimination and the choice to detain
black defendants but there are some
obvious problems with the bench rank
test and the main one is the emitted
variables problem rights the decision
makers judges almost always have more
information about the defendant than we
have as researchers so the
can talk to the defendant and
face-to-face decisions right we don't
observe as researchers everything that
the judge observes so the disparities in
detention rates could be caused by these
variables that we don't observe judges
might say look the reason I made this
decision wasn't because of the race it
was because I'm really worried about
violent offending and there were
different violent backgrounds of
different defendants so an improved test
took this insight has developed by the
economist Gary Baker
I said well judges are trying to achieve
something right they're trying to
achieve they're trying to release the
defendants who are unlikely to commit a
crime before they're before their trial
and so the outcome test is why don't we
just look at the reoffending rates just
for the defendants that judges released
so we live judges release different
groups of defendants at different rates
and we just look at Hoover fans among
the people we release and if one group
rear fins less often than another it
suggests the judges are holding that
group to a higher standard and therefore
discriminating against them so again we
can look at data from Broward County we
see the released black defendants
rear-end 47% of time whereas released
white defendants ref and 33% of the time
so affect the outcome test in this case
- the judges are discriminating
discriminating against whites now
there's a problem with the outcome test
and to understand it we need to think
about risk distributions so there's the
distribution of the probabilities
reoffending given all the information
used by the judge so you can imagine a
judge sitting in the courtroom and they
might see a hundred defendants over the
course of a week some of those
defendants are going to have you know no
previous convictions that come in for
something minor and there's a very low
chance they're going to rear end
in which case they'll be on the
left-hand side of this distribution
other defendants will have long rap
sheets and for whatever reason we
believe there are higher chance of
reoffending so they're going to be on
the right-hand side of this distribution
now over the course of a week all these
defendants are going to form this nice
distribution we're like the majority are
somewhat low risk and there's this long
tail of high-risk defendants now risk
distributions can have different Mane's
right so the mean of the distribution is
the average reoffending rate for all the
females so if we just release everyone
the mean
tells us the mean of this distribution
tells us what
one of those defendants will reoffend so
risk distribution with a higher mean
means that that group rear fins more
often on average distributions can also
have different variances this is says
that it's harder to determine whose high
risk and whose low risk for certain
groups so in this case the red
distribution is more clustered towards
the mean all the defendants in the red
group look kind of similar this might be
the case if they're it's the first time
in court we have very little information
on this defendant and so it's hard to
distinguish who's going to be high risk
who's going to be low risk whereas the
blue distribution has more mass toward
zero those are the people who are very
unlikely to reoffend and towards one the
people who are very high risk and so
it's easier to distinguish between those
different defendants now the problem
with the outcome test which we saw
suggested discrimination against whites
in Broward County is that let's say the
judge decides to apply us a threshold
that's group neutral all right
whether you're in the red group or the
blue group if there's a less than twenty
percent chance to rear-end you'll be
released
otherwise you'll be detained now let's
see what is the reoffending rate of
these release defendants if we look at
the risk distributions the reoffending
rate is the average within this shaded
section here so the average conditional
on being below the threshold and because
of there's this mess of blue defendants
really close to zero the mean
conditional on being below that
threshold is higher for the red group
lower for the blue group so the outcome
test suggests discrimination against
blue because the outcome test compares
reoffending rates why is it do that
because there's many extremely low risk
blue individuals but by construction all
defendants have faced the same threshold
so there's actually no discrimination in
this case this problem is known as a
problem of infra marginality all right
people who are very low risk will be
released whether or not judges are
biased and infer marginal statistics
such as the rear fence rate averaged
over this entire section of the of the
risk distribution and therefore they're
affected by the relative number of very
low risk defendants in different groups
because this discrimination occurs on
the margin when someone who wouldn't
have otherwise been detained is the same
because they're race we want to
and that threshold we want to know what
is that threshold for different groups
this is the general problem with
identifying bias and human decisions
prejudice manifests itself as different
thresholds but in human decisions we
can't measure those thresholds directly
we don't observe all the variables that
judges use to make their decisions and
the marginal reoffending rate there's
the threshold isn't the same as the
average reoffending rate which we
observe so now let's move on to making
decisions without rhythms right so many
jurisdictions across the u.s. these
decisions on who to release and who to
detain are informed by risk assessments
right this is a machine learned mapping
from defendant features such as the age
of current arrest whether the offense
that they charged with his violin etc to
some risk score and the risk score tends
to predict whether a defendant will
commit say a new violent crime and there
are promises here so this paper from
john klein burger at all and the
Collegium of economics suggests that
crime could be reduced by 25% in there
in new york city if they switch to using
a risk assessment with no increase in
jailing rates or jail populations could
be reduced by 42% with no increase in
crime rates and this can also happen
while reducing the percentage of African
Americans and Hispanics in jail system
there's some promises here but there's
also concerns right so as we've seen
república investigated Broward County
they found that the false positive rates
by that a certain risk assessment tool
produced were higher for black
defendants than for white defendants
right so of defendants who didn't go on
to reoffend black defendants were more
likely to be rated as high-risk so I'm
gonna go over eight potential fairness
concerns and using algorithms to make
decisions and you know I'll be talking
about this case of pre-trial risk
assessment the first is miss calibration
right so are we systematically
overestimating
a group's risk the second is redlining
we could discriminate by ignoring
relevant information about certain
groups this sample bias and this is the
situation with the potholes for example
where the training data that we use is
not representative of the problem that
we actually care about
is labeled bias when there's measurement
error in the training labels for example
we measure a wrist but what we actually
care about is crime this subgroup
validity which is when features are
differentially predictive for different
groups
there's use of protected characteristics
right including race and gender in the
model is a big fan is concern is the
disparate impact that these models can
produce which is when groups are
detained at different rates or rate at
higher risk at different rates and there
are disparate error rates as much talked
about and the false positive rates or
perhaps the false negative rates differ
between groups I'm gonna group these
fairness concerns into two groups the
first on the Left here can be fixed
without the need to sacrifice efficiency
so addressing these fairness concerns
doesn't is an intention with the goals
of the decision-maker so these are in
some sense easier perhaps not easier to
address in practice but easier to
convince the decision-maker that they
should be addressing these problems the
second set of concerns prevent present a
fairness
efficiency trade-off and these are the
trade-offs that have been discussed all
morning what I'm also going to argue is
that they present a fairness fairness
trade-off that is addressing these
concerns actually introduces different
unfairness into the decision-making
process so go through these in more
detail one by one so calibration says
that conditional on risk score group
should reoffended equal rates and this
is the way that criminologists assists
the fairness of these risk assessment
tools which they've been building so
sort of fifteen years or so and so we
can see if we plot this is per compass
again we plot the risk score from one to
ten and we look at within each bucket
what proportion of black and white
defendants rear end and we see that the
lines overlap and compass would
Northpoint the developer of compass
would use this result as evidence that
their tool is unbiased
now if you look at Broward County
something really interesting comes out
is that there's actually miss calabash
by gender so again we put the risk score
and we look at the recidivism rate and
we see that the risk of woman is
systematically overestimated by the
compass algorithm woman with the risk
score of five rear fenders bad about as
often as men with a risk score of a
three
this is seems like strong evidence of
bias against woman in this risk
assessment talk which is currently being
used in Florida the reason why
addressing calibration is an intention
with the utility of the tool is that if
we see a picture like this we're going
to over detain woman relative to men and
as a result because empirically men are
more risky there'll be more crime or
we'll have to detain more people to
achieve the same crime level so fixing
this miss calibration will improve the
effectiveness of our tool but as I said
criminologists believe that calibration
is sufficient for fairness or some of
them do and often in computer science
there's also a group that believes that
calibration is sufficient but we argue
that it's not and the reason for this is
that there are many possible risk scores
that are calibrated right but and that
aren't the best estimate of risk so you
know most logistic regressions that you
fit on some problem will end up being
calibrated but because there's so many a
biased decision-maker could pick and
choose the one that achieves that it
most advantages the favored group or
most disadvantages there unfavored group
right yeah
yeah I'll cover that I'll cover that bit
you're exactly right this is a tension
between the law as it stands and that's
this concern yeah and I should point out
that this could happen with a biased
decision-maker who's explicitly
discriminating but it could also just be
oversight right the designer ignores
some feature that could significantly
improve the performance for one group
but it just fails to include it the
reason we use the term redlining for
this is by analogy to lending
discrimination right where banks ignored
the individual creditworthiness of
minority applicants or applicants and
minority neighborhoods and such a policy
could be calibrated in the sense that
those minority neighborhoods might have
had lower average sorry higher average
default risk so the men can say well
we're not not lending to that group
because of their race their lower risk
on average but the problem is that
they're ignored the qualifications that
any individual borrower in those
neighborhoods could have right so this
red lining problem is when information
is ignored in such a way to discriminate
do you an example of how it works
imagine this is the world there's white
defendants and black defendants and the
only thing that affects whether they're
likely to rear fenders the number of
previous convictions they have right so
with zero previous convictions
defendants rayon 5% of time one to two
convictions 20% of the time three or
more convictions support extended time
both groups reoffended on a bridge 20%
of the time now a possible calibrated
risk score is first for a black
defendants we put them into three
buckets based on the number of previous
convictions for white defendants we
ignore their number previous convictions
and just put everyone in the in the
middle bucket right because on average
white defendants rear-end 20% of time
which is just as often as black
defendants in the second bucket riffing
so this is a calibrated role because
everyone in the second bucket with a
white or black Rifkin's 20% of time
but now we can apply a 25% threshold so
we say we detain anyone with the greater
than 25% chance of reoffending we only
end up detaining the third bucket
we only in a bit end up detaining black
defendants so we've got a calibrated
risk score we've got a uniform threshold
that doesn't depend on the race of the
defendant and yet we're only detaining
black defendants in this example this
points to a general way to discriminate
if you're a bad actor where you can just
add noise to the risk scores of favored
group so you train your model and let's
say you want to favor white defendants
and initially they have this sort of
risk distribution here where there's
like some defendants who are pretty high
risk and quite a few that have the
features indicating they're low risk and
use adding noise to that model right
what adding noise does is it blurs the
distinction between high risk and low
risk defendants and what that looks like
in risk distributions is the mass moves
towards the main right everyone starts
looking more and more similar and you
just keep adding noise until the vast
majority of the group you're trying to
favor is below the threshold and we look
at the calibration plot here the risk
score and the actual probability of
reoffending both algorithms the black
original scores and the red doctored
scores both calibrated and yet now
you're detaining no white defendants so
in the lending example we were ignoring
information about the disfavored group
in this barrel example we ignore
information about the favored group but
the mechanism is the same so calibration
is necessary but not sufficient for
fairness and the reason I say it's
necessary is that without calibration
it's unclear what it means to have a
risk score so if you ask me how risky is
this defendant and I say there are two
and you say what does that mean and I
say well if the if they're male that
means there's a 50% chance there if and
if they're female it means there's a 20%
chance there or if and you can see how
who loses its meaning in that case as a
risk or the risk score
like once you've got golden the binary
classifier resulting from job losses
calibration anywhere and losses like the
Precision's won't be equal well the the
binary predicted is going to depend on
who's far away from the margin right so
if if there happens to be a lot more
murderers in one one sample then there
gonna be a lot of obviously high-risk
people which is going to drive up your
precision for that group without saying
anything about how you're treating
defendants on the margin and so it's
it's equalizing that precision is less
important because it depends on those
defendants that are further away from
the margin right and that's that's a
sort of subset of this by decreasing the
number of values you're obscuring
information that could be used to make
distinctions between between defendants
yeah that yeah so looking at the sense
of attribute decision time versus adding
it to the model and therefore ensuring
it's calibrated I like to size the same
coin so because of this you can't
determine fairness wagon without
inspecting the features used right
because we could have the the designer
could have excluded some feature that in
order to discriminate and one way to
avoid this problem is to use all the
available features which also produces
the most accurate diagram which is why
republic wiring calibration sorry
avoiding redlining is in the interests
of the decision maker so a third
fairness concern is sample bias rights
of the data set that we're training on
is sample from the population in a
biased way so an example of this might
be predictive policing algorithms that
are trained on policing over from
historical data where over-policing was
present in minority neighborhoods and as
a result they're going to predict that
crime will continue to occur in the
neighborhoods where policing discovered
that crime initially again this is in
the interests of the decision maker to
address because the city wants to limit
crime and so knowing that there are
crime in areas where we didn't sample
from it's going to improve our results
on that metric so again addressing
sample bias is in the interest of the
decision maker this also label bias
right so again over policing in minority
neighborhoods might mean that if a white
and black person both committed an
offense the black person is more likely
to be arrested and a pair as a positive
in our data because we observe arrests
where I said what we actually want to
predict is crimes this is a real problem
right so if you're training a risk
assessment on drug arrests you're going
to systematically overestimate the risk
of minority defendants well
criminologist use to address this is
that they use violent crime as their
outcome and that's because they find no
evidence that the probability of being
arrested given committed a crime is
greater for one race or another it's
over arrested for a violent crime is the
least biased outcome that we have
available to us
finally there's subgroup validity yeah
sorry you know even if you don't make an
arrest and people are not policing
certain neighborhoods you still know
where their crime is how great in that
or not it's usually quite hard right so
you could use right so things like
robberies it's much easier to detect
where crime is occurring but things like
drug crimes you know there's probably a
lot of drug crimes happening in Berkeley
dorms right now that we'll never find
out about and and generally measuring
the true crime rate is a challenging
problem right which the reason we use
violent crime is that it's easier to
determine because of like victim reports
it's easy to determine the true crime
rate so finally this subgroup validity
right so I talk about bias and the
labels and thing we're trying to predict
but there's also bias in the input
features right so if we use drug arrests
in our model and we know the drug
arrests are biased in the sense that
condition on committing a drug crime
minorities are more likely to be
arrested would expect that using drug
arrests would overestimate the risk of
minority defendants right and what we'll
see if this is the case is miss
calibration but the advantage of bias or
the the the saving grace of bias in the
input features as long as the labels are
unbiased we can learn to correct these
biases with the appropriate interactions
so an example outside of criminal
justice might be that we're trying to
predict who will succeed in a job and we
noticed that men who have extended
periods of joblessness perhaps that's a
negative predictor of future job
performance whereas women who have it
say a year off are often just on
maternity leave and it has no bearing on
whether they'll be successful in the job
without knowing whether the applicant as
a man or a woman we can't learn to
correct that bias but if we know we can
correct it again this is the picture we
see in Broward County and if we just add
gender to this model we're going to
correct this bias and and stop the
taining woman at higher rates
so now look at the second set of
fairness concerns that present this
fairness fairness trade-off the first of
the use of predictacator effects and
we've talked about this already today
it's legally questionable under the
current law so adding ginger to this
model
to fix this miss calibration is probably
illegal and the current understanding of
an anti classification laws but it's
probably all in the universe of the
University of Pennsylvania Law Review
discussed there may be cases where
allowing an algorithm to consider
protected classed can actually make
outcomes fair this might require a
doctrinal shift is in many cases
considering particular status in a
decision is presumptively illegal harm
okay so we know that in theory there are
lots of situations where adding a
particular character to the model
actually makes it more fair but
currently the legal understanding is
that betters not allowed
another concern we might have is about
disparate impact writers when one group
is detained more often than another and
this is often encoded in computer
science papers at statistical parity all
right there acquirements that all groups
be detained at equal rates or that the
decision should be independent of
particular characteristics we look at
Broward County we see that 57% of black
defendants was rated as high-risk this
is through 33% of white defendants so
there's disparate impact in the campus
scores and Broward County but there's a
problem with school parity as a measure
of fairness right it's an aglet and
neljä goes to the benchmark test which I
talked about at the start of the talk
right the differences in detention rates
might reflect differences in risk and we
can't see that just by comparing this
scores we can partially mitigated with
controls which some authors refer to as
conditionals of school parity so you
might say that conditional on the age of
the defendant and the number of previous
convictions we shouldn't see different
detention rates among different groups
but there's always the question of what
do we control for there's also disparate
error rates all right so this is the
false positive rates should be equal for
all groups and to positive rate of
course is the number of detained
defendants who wouldn't have gone to
rear end divided by the number of
defendants who wouldn't have gone on to
reorient and this is ProPublica evidence
of bias encompass
is that this ratio was higher for black
defendants than white defendants so we
can look again in Broward County 42% of
black defendants who didn't go on to
rear fend for eight at high risk whereas
22% of white defendants who didn't go on
to riffian rate at high risk so where
did these disparities come from and
where they come from is that the risk
distributions for black and white
defendants have different shapes right
so in blue here is the risk distribution
for white defendants and in red is the
restriction for black defendants and
once you choose a threshold in the space
so you can decide whether you want to be
very strict and detained almost everyone
or you can decide if you want to be
lenient but once you choose a threshold
everything else is determined right the
detention rates and how they differ the
false positive rates and how they differ
the optimal policy is a single threshold
in the sense that detaining the riskiest
ex defendants means that you'll detain
the fewest number of defendants for a
given acceptable crime rate or
alternatively you'll minimize crime for
a given number of defendants detained
but even if average recidivism rates are
equal they could still be differences in
the shapes of these distributions so the
mean of these two distributions is the
same so on average both groups riaf end
equally often but once we apply a
threshold anything goes there could be
disparate detention rates they could be
disparate false positive rates
what we show in our paper and Mercer has
talked about this is that the optimal
policy that equalizes detention rates or
false positive rates uses very specific
thresholds and then this means there's a
tension between individual fairness
right that all defendants should be held
to the same standard and group the
fairness that we should try to equalize
the tension rates or false positive
rates so what this looks like might
might be something like this where we
choose to detain black defendants if
there's a greater that if they score
greater than a seven on the risk scale
but we choose to detain white defendants
of their score greater than five and
what's the result of this and we can
look again at the Broward County to see
what Broward County data to see what
happens here so first of all there are
some low-risk defendants that were
detained because of their race right
these are the the white defendants here
who score of five or six they wouldn't
have been detained if they were black
and if we equalized a false positive
rates in the Broward County data that
those defendants will make up 14% of the
total number of defendants that we
detain right and these defendants will
bring a Fourteenth Amendment case
alleging that their equal protection
rights have been a bridge because as I
say they wouldn't have been detained had
they been a member of a different race
but is the other side of it which is
that because we're detaining low-risk
defendants while releasing some
relatively higher risk defendants
there's going to be an increase in
violent crime committed by release
defendants and because we know that
crime generally occurs within
communities as opposed to between
communities this crime will be
concentrated in minority neighborhoods
and the victims will also bring a
Fourteenth Amendment case right so they
say you released a defendant into my
neighborhood who wouldn't have released
into a white neighborhood and as a
result I was victimized and because of
this a statistical likelihood some
number of those defendants will go on to
commit crimes so therefore my Fourteenth
Amendment rights had been violated
so there's costs here to fairness from
both sides both the people who are newly
detained and the increase in violent
crime resulted from the people who are
released so we can see analogies between
these these measures of fairness and a
test for discrimination that I talked
about at the start of the talk right so
as measures of fairness disparate impact
and disparate error rates face the same
problems
as they're related test for
discrimination and human decisions we've
already seen that disparate impact is
similar to the benchmark test and that
both compare rates of detention but
ignore the possibility that different
risks might necessitate different
detention rates disparate rates is
similar to the outcome test and that
both compare infra marginal statistics
they both competitor sex that include
not only defendants close to the margin
where discrimination might occur but
also defendants far from the margin
where the decision wouldn't be changed
either way to flesh that out a bit
consider this toy example right we have
some defendants in a blue group and some
risk assessment algorithm has scored
these defendants and it's a calibrated
algorithm in the sense that if this
defender has a point four percent chance
of reoffending forty percent of the time
they'll rear-end and we have this orange
group that has a higher mean they
reaffirm more often on average and we
decide to detain defendants if there's a
greater than fifty percent chance that
will reoffending we can look up false
positive rates we see that this group
has a twenty five percent false positive
rate whereas this group has a 42 percent
false positive rate this is roughly the
picture that ProPublica saw when they
studied Broward County well what happens
up before they came to study Broward
County the police in that County
strictly enforced say jaywalking laws or
some other minor law in the district and
as a result there are a lot more
low-risk defendants of the orange group
detained so a lot more low-risk
defendants came into the system right
and because they've only been caught
jaywalking there's a very low chance
they'll rear fender and so we don't
detain any of them they just get
released now let's look at what's
happened to the false positive rates the
introduction of these low-risk
defendants has reduced the false
positive rate to twenty six percent and
in so ProPublica came and studied this
version of Broward County where the cops
were being a bit overzealous on the
orange group they would find no
discrimination according to their
measure right so let's see what's
happened the risk assessment algorithm
hasn't changed right everyone scores are
still the same no defendants decision
has changed right everyone to the right
of the threshold to stoop to the right
of the threshold different to the left
of the threshold is still to the left of
the threshold
and yet the false positive rates tell
totally different stories in this
picture weird find discrimination
against the orange group whereas in this
picture we don't see any discrimination
according to the false positive rate
metric this is the exact problem that we
saw in the outcome test the problem of
introversion ality and the problem is
that false positive rates are confounded
as a measure of discrimination by the
distribution of obviously high risk and
obviously lower risk defendants so in
this example we added a lot of obviously
low-risk defendants and we could change
the false positive rates without
changing anyone's decision now in the
problem of studying human decisions we
don't have a way of measuring the
threshold right but in our government
decisions we can directly observe and
change the threshold this is our
prescription for making fair decisions
without rooms ensure the following
concerns that addressed so we want to
make sure that there's no miss
collaboration there's no redlining that
features not being ignored because that
in order to discriminate there's no
sample bias that we've adequately
addressed labeled bias and that we've
addressed subgroup validity problems and
a lot of these concerns require
transparency so at least a government
auditor or someone like that has to be
able to look into the algorithm and how
it was constructed the training set that
was used to construct it in order to
determine that these are fairness
concerns have been addressed and once we
have a risk assessment that satisfies
those concerns then we choose a single
threshold to make our decision there are
some limitations to this approach some
decisions such as college admissions
don't operate on on individuals they
apply to groups so when we're admitting
students to college we don't want to
pick just the hundred students that are
most likely to graduate we want to pick
the class of a hundred that is going to
be most successful and there's
interactions between between students in
that case our analysis also doesn't
consider long-term equilibrium so Mertz
talked about how you might be willing to
trade off some utility now to achieve a
better long-term outcome in computer
science people often talk about
exploration versus exploitation where
maybe we don't have enough information
about one group so we we change how
we're releasing people to explore better
how they would perform if we release
them
and now analysis also doesn't consider
the possibility that some of defendants
could be more costly to detain so for
example a single mother with dependent
children might it might be more costly
to society and to her to detain her then
detaining a young man so that's my talk
for today thanks very much and take
questions
yeah yeah the reason for that is because
they depend both on what's happening
around where the decisions are made so
they were like there are always going to
be defendants where it's like it it's a
tough decision whether they should be
detained or not right and that's where
the race might tip the balance
for example whereas there's going to be
defendants where it's very easy to make
the decision whether it's very obvious
that they're not going to rear-end again
or it's very obvious that they're
high-risk and need to be detained false
positive rates and and detention rates
averaged over both groups and so what's
happening among the really high-risk and
really low-risk defendants can change
our assessment of what's happening where
the hard decisions are where race can
tip the balance and that's what people
who study human decisions have realized
in their tests for discrimination and
we're trying to bring that insight into
determining with algorithms of fear
yeah how are these thresholds like same
or you want to you have some kind of
adversarial system where you give
someone a classifier and then they have
to apply it they want to be as as able
as possible to discriminate with regards
to something and then they don't really
care about fairness but you want to make
sure that your classifier is robust so
that whatever you give them even if they
play around with the threshold in a
little bit they can't make it too unfair
right so this is the example maybe where
judges get given as is the case now
judges get given a risk score I'd say
this the offenders are seven but they
sin the end they still make the decision
so you can imagine them deviating a long
way from from the policy suggested by
the algorithm I think we don't really
have evidence on on what judges are
doing in that case the the strict rule
would just be like get judges out of the
way because they might add more bias
than they actually solve if we're
concerned about them them fudging with
the thresholds but yeah I don't I don't
think we know exactly how judges are
using these scores in any situation if
you let the decision make it miss with
the threshold it's going to deviate from
what I've discussed right it's going to
be presumably it's either going to
result in disparities in false positive
rates or something or it's going to
sacrifice some efficiency yeah
so in this case it seems like once the
judges are made aware of the potential
bias and in the discourse predicted by
conquest yes for the same school I would
have done this but make me now to vote
back right so it might be an apocryphal
story but I've heard I've heard that one
particular dogged activist is going
around to judges that saying mentally
take two points off whenever you have a
woman in your courtroom right and you
can see why because the gap here there's
two points and so taking that two points
off a woman means that now you're
actually comparing real risk and yeah
again that's that's good in the sense
that would stop us from discriminating
its woman but I think right I think I
think if judges explicitly said I'm
taking two points off for one that's
when you get into the realm of one now
you're using a particular characteristic
to make decisions and under current
understanding of discrimination law that
might be illegal so even though there
are these there's this miss calibration
addressing it might be like and I think
there's definitely room for a court case
to it to correct then celebrating model
was down to finding features if you like
yeah we could use hair lengths to
calibrate yeah yeah you've built a proxy
for the sense of attribute which means
your model can color to calibrate itself
and this problem goes away but in some
sense you know I suppose the law is
concerned if all you did was he found a
proxy yeah well yeah well I'm actually
advocating for using the thing itself
here because that's how we can ensure
that the algorithm is calibrated a look
using gender right I mean we could use
proxies to like maybe try and get around
the law but
because essentially where you hide but
yeah that means that also is tension
with absolutely yeah and I think I think
so like using an example like this in a
court case is where you might get a
decision finding that actually using
predictive characters can improve
fairness
[Applause]